RACHEL DEACON SMITH: Hi.
In this video, I'll
show you how you
can replicate data
from an Oracle database
into BigQuery using Cloud
Data Fusion's replication
accelerator.
My name's Rachel Deacon Smith,
and I'm a developer advocate
at Google Cloud.
If you're an ETL developer
or a data analyst,
you may want to continuously
replicate your operational data
into BigQuery in real time,
so you can make timely,
data driven business decisions.
Data Fusions, with a
driven accelerator,
integrates with Data
Stream, Google Cloud's
serverless and easy to use,
change data capture service.
This end-to-end
Cloud native solution
will fuel your
analytic environment
with instant insights,
removing the need
to develop bespoke and
high maintenance solutions.
So let's jump into the demo.
Creating a new replication
job with Cloud Data Fusion
is super easy.
You first want to launch Data
Fusion from Cloud console,
and you can find this
under the Big Data section.
If you don't have a Cloud
Data Fusion instance yet,
you'll need to create one.
So you'll need to specify
some basic parameters
such as the instance
name and the region,
and you'll also need to add
the replication accelerator.
You'll also need to make
sure that both the Data
Fusion and Dataproc
service accounts
have the Data Stream admin
role assigned to them,
and you can do this from
the [INAUDIBLE] page
in the Google Cloud console.
OK, so once your
instance is ready,
you're now ready to
configure your Oracle
to BigQuery replication.
So we'll just click on
the tile named Replicate,
and then on the big
green button selecting
Create a replication job.
Setting up the
replication is super easy,
because we have a wizard
driven UI that will guide you
through the entire process.
So you just need to provide
a name and a description,
and then you can select
the source database type.
So while you can replicate
from MySQL or SQL server,
we're interested in replicating
from an Oracle source,
so we'll put Oracle
by Datastream.
And then we need to provide
the source connection details,
so we'll need to
enter the region.
We need to provide the
hostname and the port.
We need to give a
system identifier
and add any credentials
that we need
to connect to our database.
We also want to bring with
us a historical backfill,
so we'll leave the Replicate
Existing Data setting enabled.
Next, you want to pick
the source objects,
so these are the
tables in the columns
that you want to replicate.
So for example,
in a given table,
we can choose whether
to replicate all columns
or to select a subset of columns
that we want to replicate.
We can also choose the type
of events to replicate,
such as inserts,
updates, and deletes.
Once we're happy
with our selection,
we can just click Next
to configure the target.
Since Cloud Data Fusion
is fully integrated
with the rest of Google
Cloud's ecosystem,
configuring the BigQuery
target is pretty simple.
You just provide some
basic information,
such as the BigQuery data set
name, and you're ready to go.
You can actually
leave the data set
details blank to default to
the name of the source database
or schema.
So we can click Next
to configure now
the advanced properties.
So if you have a good
idea on the amount of data
that you're planning
to replicate,
you can tweak the replication
configuration here.
So for example,
how much data you
expect to replicate in an hour.
I'm happy with this as it is,
so I won't make any changes.
Once the source and target
details are provided,
the replication wizard
will automatically
perform a pre-deployment
assessment
and proactively advise you
on any potential issues prior
to the replication deployment.
So for example, it can point out
any schema compatibility issues
between the source and the
target, and in this case,
the assessment has indicated
that we're missing a feature.
So by clicking on the missing
features link, I can drill down
into the issue,
and in this case,
realize that I'm
missing a primary key.
So once I fix my
problems in the source,
I can just click the Refresh
button on the top right corner
and move on to the Summary page.
After reviewing all the
parameters provided,
all that's left to do is
click the Deploy Replication
Job to start your job.
And once the
replication is running,
monitoring is super simple.
You can natively monitor
the replication progress,
the errors, and the
throughput and latency
via a centralized
and easy to use UI.
And now once your
data is in BigQuery,
you'll be ready to run
real-time analytics
or build a robust reporting
platform by connecting
to business
intelligence services,
like Looker, to build powerful,
real-time business dashboards
ultimately allowing you to
take immediate actions based
on streaming data.
So that's it.
I've quickly shown
you how to easily
replicate data from
an Oracle database
into BigQuery using a wizard
driven Cloud Data Fusion
accelerator that is
integrated with Google
Cloud serverless and easy
to use CDC Offering I
hope you've enjoyed it.
So you can get started from the
Google Cloud console or learn
more at
cloud.google.com/data-fusion.
Thanks so much for watching.